mark fischbach better known as
markiplier is one of the biggest YouTube
stars in the world with over 16 million
subscribers first while all his fans are
familiar with his high energy reactions
in his let's play videos there's
actually a lot more to him than just
shouting and playing games here are
eight things the world needs to know
about markiplier regular guy before he
became one of the Internet's most famous
personalities markiplier was just a
regular dude born in Honolulu Hawaii he
studied engineering at the University of
Cincinnati but he didn't end up
graduating instead using his engineering
skills to dominate building games like
poly bridge while entertaining his fan
sounds like a win-win
he taught Jimmy Kimmel the rope late
night show personality Jimmy Kimmel once
said that he thought that watching let's
play videos was a waste of time after
the internet ganged up on him Kimmel
invited markiplier and fellow let's play
star mrs. Mae to teach him the ropes and
explain just what he was missing
hey will you tell the people not to kill
me no no we're still waiting for Kimmel
so let's play Channel to launch but this
seems like a pretty good start anyway
he's afraid of mannequins like most
people there are things out in the world
of Caremark more specifically mannequins
and dolls give him a major case of the
heebie-jeebies
why are they all staring at me carries
on steadily either way Oh No are they
all creepy creepy creepy that may not
sound like a big deal but as anyone who
watches his channel knows that
mannequins and dolls seem to appear a
lot more often in video games and you
might expect which is great for our
entertainment but not so great for
markiplier anxiety levels
I'll get out here okay hi margarita man
mark was presented with the taco trophy
an object that we envied deeply by
Rachel Ray for having created an amazing
margarita turns out that markiplier once
worked as a bartender
which explains why he's so familiar with
how to make a great one knowledge he
shared with his thirty son and you don't
need to add a lot of zest to it you just
need to make one and then garnish it
because presentation is 50% of
everything he took a hiatus mark took a
brief hiatus from YouTube following the
death of a close friend of his Daniel
kiyah Daniel was part of cyndago a
comedy group on YouTube that focused on
dark humour usually of satirical nature
Daniel reached out to Mars to
collaborate with him on projects and
they ended up becoming roommates and
close friends on September 18th 2015
kaya passed away from brain damage after
an attempted suicide daniel was such an
influence on what we did he was such an
inspiration for what I did Marc went to
talk on YouTube for about a month before
returning to his work misery loves
company this might cause you to look
away in abject horror but mark has joint
hypermobility in his legs
meaning that he can move his knees
beyond their normal range
as though he got hit with a sledgehammer
by Kathy Bates as far as party tricks go
this one is downright repulsive but you
also kind of can't look away once he
starts doing it
the snapshot incident in 2015 as fun
claims of market abusive power of
celebrity and exploited enough for nude
photos on the popular app snapchat
screenshotting a topless photo that he
accidentally sent to him mark later
denied the allegations claiming that the
fana continually send him nude photos
despite his request that she stopped and
that he never took a screenshot of any
of them the incident resulted in
markiplier quitting snapshot for good
it's just a banana for April Fool's Day
2016
mark uploaded a video titled marks
contemplates the banana for five minutes
the joke apparently was that he was very
popular he can literally post anything
at all and people would still
what well the joke's on us because he's
been proven right as more than two and a
half million people have watched him
what's up banana
no spoilers it still hasn't done
anything particularly appealing thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your lipstick
[Music]